how is uh fatherhood going for you
enjoying fatherhood i do enjoy it
um it's difficult um it gets easier
though it's one of those things that
gets easier
i had a dog once and that doesn't get
easier it doesn't
it's harder having a dog because
children develop and dogs just stay
dumb and they never figure it out
and when you're i don't know if you ever
had a dog that's had a medical problem
but you can't get their cooperation
when you that you need to help them
because you can't say them you know you
have this problem you see
yeah i had this dog when i took my dog
to the vet the first time
uh she was a i don't know a year old
when i adopted her and the vet told me
don't let your dog eat dark chocolate i
don't know if you know this but i've
heard this that yeah it's
dark chocolate is supposed to be poison
to dogs kills them and vets won't
explain it further either
it's like why does it kill them oh just
they die like they won't tell you what
like what do i do if my dog eats dark
chocolate watch her die or leave the
room
so
but the vet did tell me there's one
thing you can do
which is give your dog hydrogen peroxide
and that foams up in the dog's belly and
then they throw it up with the chocolate
that's
what you should know to do that but uh
you gotta do it quickly before they
ingest the chocolate
all right so i come home like uh six
months later sure enough my dog gets
dark chocolate i had friends who had
stayed over and they didn't know they
left dark chocolate in low places
right which is very uh
[Laughter]
here's a good place for this yes
i could put it on this high shelf but i
think not
they put it way down i may be crawling
on the floor later that's right
it might not need a snack so what so
you're calling my dog
had your dog eating eating a whole big
bar of darts polish chocolate
the polish part doesn't matter but i
like saying polish chocolate
and my dog had chocolate on her face
and and i went oh my god and she looked
at me like i was home for an hour alone
what are you gonna you know come on
and i was like you're gonna die and
she's looking at me like i don't
understand english but i get that you're
upset
and uh and so i'm thinking i gotta get
hydrogen peroxide into this dog but i
don't have any so i've got to go to the
pharmacy and she needs to come with me
because there's no time
i'm in new york city and i take my i put
the leash on her she's like excited
we're going for a walk
and i'm running and she's like this is
great for you you never exercise she's
just enjoying it
and then we get to the pharmacy and
she's waiting for me when i come out and
i've got a bottle of hydrogen peroxide
that i have to make her
drink yeah like take yourself through
that how do you
make a dog like you just hear drink this
you know so i kind of pour a little in
her snout and she goes
like that and so i kind of grab her and
i pour them once she
she goes i think i was pretty clear that
i didn't like that like she looks at me
like
she's trying to figure out what's going
on here and so i get my whole body
around her this dog was 70 pounds she
was like an alligator and if she didn't
want to drink something
she was just thrashing i'm like drink it
and at one point i have her on the end
of the leash and she's looking at me
all wet in the face and she gives me
this look like i don't know what
happened to you
but our thing is over
i'm a dog and she starts going all right
she became completely vicious
she's trying to bite me and i'm trying
to save her life yeah so i'm literally
i'm
punching her in the face and splashing
this stuff i'm holding her here
kicking her in the stomach
and people i look and there's hundreds
of people on the sidewalk
just horrifying yeah there's cars
stopping they're honking at me
she's gonna die i'm like this is a
nightmare and finally i got enough in
up her nose and whatever and she was
like
dude uh just huh
and then she just like a pump just and
just
brown foam yeah brown like she's like
another dog is coming out of her
and she made it but
she never liked me after that she hated
me because from her point of view i just
went
no you went nuts i lost my reason i hate
dogs
[ __ ] dogs are like the slaves or the
animal kingdom
[ __ ] i know the rest of the animals
will be like oh sell out [ __ ]
do anything them two-legged
[ __ ] tell you to do cause the
dog just like to say
sit yourself now roll those eyes are
rolling
fetch the stick i don't know what you
wanted for but [ __ ] it i'm gonna go get
it
you know i'm saying i can't stand a dog
and i think people that have dogs need a
lot of affection
cause you know when you get home your
dogs run up on you
[Music]
what you mean i miss you like a mother
let me lick your ass
come here let me stop it here [ __ ] me in
there
i can't take that much affection get the
[ __ ] off me
you know what i'm saying i got two cats
i like cats cause cats are independent
like myself
i don't need all that affection [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying cats don't play
that [ __ ] try and tell a cat
to sit [ __ ] cat gonna look at you like
all right [ __ ] i'm gonna tear
these curtains up
till you figure out who's running [ __ ]
around here
put some food my [ __ ] ball
and my two cash names are socks and
shoes
damn cause socks he's the oldest [ __ ]
and all four's pawns are white except
for the hind one nigga's white up to
here like he's from the east coast [ __ ]
one leg up
and then little shoes he's the third no
he got issues with shoes in his face you
know you walk
past him [ __ ] [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
anytime [ __ ] anytime
you know i'm saying socks gonna be
letting the [ __ ] walk all
around you [ __ ] pull them knives a
[ __ ] i don't get all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] when i come in the door then
[ __ ] don't even flinch
eating up all my [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm taking
care of them [ __ ] no mother i open the
door they even looking like that
[ __ ] [ __ ] him [ __ ] you doing here
we damn you out of water [ __ ] get to
work
you know and so one day i came home i
was feeling kind of down and [ __ ]
so i'm sitting down [ __ ] and cats you
know animals can sense when you're kind
of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] they both jumped up on a [ __ ]
left he just looked up at me
what's wrong man i ain't never seen you
like this man
no [ __ ] gonna rub me you can rub
you know whatever that [ __ ] is man you
got to let that go man
[ __ ] that [ __ ] man she wasn't worthy i
didn't like the [ __ ] when you brought
over here
oh that [ __ ] is a night fighter man
trying to have that [ __ ] out today like
scared the [ __ ] out of me
let me get two more rubs here that's
enough
don't last on this [ __ ] too long [ __ ]
you just get back to yourself [ __ ]
and put some food in my [ __ ]
bowl
i went down to the pound i got one of
those free dogs
free dog that's how i say it too i don't
say i rescued a dog i hate when people
say that stuff they say hey
she's a rescue i rescued her really did
you pull her out of a burning building
did you jump in a river with your
wingtips still on with no concern for
your own safety
or did you just go down to the pound and
get a free dog your cheap [ __ ]
is that what you did
i actually i did not want to get a
rescue dog i did not want to do that my
girl was all about it
she's like we should rescue a dog you
want to rescue a dog i'm like no
no i don't she's like why not i go
because i think a lot of the dogs down
the pile might be a little [ __ ] in
their head
you ever thought about that dude the
shelter is not a pet store that is like
shawshank for a golden retriever
why don't we just go down to the prison
and rescue an inmate just roll the dice
that maybe the guy was wrongly convicted
you under your mind [ __ ] that i want a
brand new 2009 bulldog all right
i don't want some 1995 half a labrador
or part of its ear chewed off you know i
gotta put together
its backstory every time i go to use the
toaster it starts freaking out
cause his last owner hung him from the
ceiling fan every time the jets didn't
cover the over you know
dude that's an animal man that that
could kill you
dude a rabbit squirrel how fast the
squirrel is if i was walking home at
night minding my own business
all of a sudden some squirrels started
running at me by the time i
processed like is that a rat is that
mechanical that that would be up my
leg taking chunks out of the side of my
head i'd have to tell that story for the
rest of my life in a bar
dude what happened inside of your head a
[ __ ] squirrel all right
twice you don't think i'm sensitive
no i'm not trying to say all those dogs
are bad down there but what if i
accidentally get one of those cujos or
old yellers
right i'm telling you they love dogs
down there so much you got to watch out
what they tell you
i was down there there was this one dog
this thing was staring at me so goddamn
hearts
maniac hook and dog i'm like what's up
with this dog she was just like oh he
was chained to a pallet in a junkyard
his entire life and i'm like does it
have any issues she's like
he's a little aggressive
it's like were you gonna tell me that
[ __ ] you're just gonna throw at my
hatchback
let me figure it out on the ride home
something's pulling out a sharpened
toothbrush to stick in my neck
that's what i'm saying what if i
accidentally get one of those crazy dogs
i get up at two in the morning to take a
leak and that is the exact moment
its previous owner used to come home
shit-faced beat the crap out of the dog
i have no idea what i'm setting off i'm
sitting there shuffling along and my
slippers trying my robe
meanwhile the dog's getting all amped up
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] man i promised
myself i won't let this happen again
it's time to man up let's do this on
three one two three
i'm gonna be landing the ground in a
pool of my own blood
what are you gonna do with the dog they
take him right back down to the pound
like some sort of repeat offender
you're gonna see him on the news and
like shackles like shuffling along
we knew you'd be back there get me a
milk bone go [ __ ] yourself
you're gonna wheel him in like hannibal
lecter with that lampshade around his
neck
anyway i give all married men the same
advice
gay or straight get a dog
this dog will love you all the time but
she's not going to
it's real talk i didn't even i didn't
even know about dogs and my kids got the
dog
they brought them home from the shelter
and i didn't even want them they're like
can we keep them i said nope
i said where'd you even get this dog
they're like we got him from the shelter
i was like ugh
probably something wrong with them
can't keep them and then my kids started
crying and screaming like the dog had
gambling debts
please dad if you don't let us keep them
they're going to kill them
all right you can keep him and his dog
was a menace
i hated his guts then one night i had
smoked a bunch of weed
and i was eating a sandwich and baba i
came home by was a dog he came over and
was staring at me this would make you
very uncomfortable if you're just
looking at you
i had to give him a piece of my sandwich
so he'd go away and that's how we became
friends
now if you see me walking down the
street with baba i ain't got no
leash or nothing he walks right next to
me if i if i stop he'll stop and if i go
he'll go and all my friends are like yo
dave that [ __ ] is dope how you training
boba to do that [ __ ]
i've never trained baba just a messy
eater
if i drop food and baba's not around all
i gotta do is call him
baba he's a black dude's dog so they
didn't come right away he
peeks first to see what's going on
[Applause]
i gotta tap my foot so we can see the
food over here little buddy
and he's like thanks david he'll come
get it and run off
but he knows all my habits like if he
smells weed in the house he'll be like
this [ __ ] about to eat and i'll
just come running